Soon According to the World Health
Organization 13 1.1 Billion Smokers in the
World Today Rain Continues Dot Number
Effective Entries 1.6 Billion More Than a Time
The Current President Subscribe Not Decide What's
The Language In A Different Modes
In Every Day And Treatments And The Only Thing That Can
Protect Your Immune System From
Unity On This Occasion Hi Guys Welcome To Make
Us Of Unity Smoking System Can Make A
New System Birds
Protecting Itself From Infections
And Eases They Suicide Everything From Cold
And Flu Virus To Serious Conditions Like
Cancer
That Cigarette Smoke Contain More  Than 700 Chemical
Compounds Always Too New This Arm Hole
Including Hydrogen Cyanide Carbon
Monoxide Ammonia Next 250 Not Harmful
Chemicals in Tobacco Smoke At Least 60
Cancers Smoking Cigarettes and Use These
Chemicals in Two Parts Divide
Distribution of Chemicals Based on
A Star is Word for Solid  Participated
in Tobacco Smoke Difficult Content Chemicals Including Polish
Cyclic Aromatic
Hydrocarbons Vision Carcinogens Torsa
See Brown Institute Finger Nails
Jewelers Ans A Co
Confess Monoxide In this episode of Pause
Just End Colors and Please Click on This
Day Take Place of Oxygen and Carbon
Monoxide Gas 2010  Is
I Sequence Monitor Lizard Oxidizing
Chemicals Which Highly Active Chemicals And
Misery Heart Muscles And Blood Vessels Delhi
To Heart Disease Stroke And With That
Cigarette Smoke Also Contains Lord Of
Metals Like Arsenic Beryllium Cadmium
Chromium Co Bal Pluto Nickel Human Body
System Price Of Billions Of  Cells Dega
Skin Organs Blood Vessels and Immune
System Unit Blood Cells Tata Power System Se Different
Types of Side Subscribe
Like and Subscribe Body System Must Continue
Satisfying System Cannot Give Up All
Subscribe Thank You for Watching See You
Thank You Kisi Liya
And  Microscopic Her Life
Protection Present Voice of Respiratory
System Including Muslims and Airways
Third YouTube Channel About Twenty Thousand
Times and Way Around You Can Trust and the Bare Own
Political Statement Complete We Flip
Apart Tablet in the Blanks with Serious
Cigarette Sticky Mucus Which Translates
Particles and  Prevents Him From
Settling In Ears As Well As This Serum Moves Backwards
And Forwards And Coordinated
Web Like Motion Moved With Mucus Out Of
Clans This Ordinary That Is Alarms Clean
And Free From Infection According To The
American Long Association With Harmful
Chemicals Industries Maruti Alto K10
Resulting  In Pales and Inability to
Effectively Treat Little Boys This
Quartz Infection Recent Studies Have Shown That
Smoking is Not Only Seen from Moving
Cars Volume Maximum Previous Report Witch Will
Be Destroyed Completely Lacking Even More
Vulnerable Toe Infections Smoking Increases
The President of the System
Subscribe Viral and Bacterial Infections
Specifically for examples in infections
subscribe skin types of cancers
that are different from decreasing f81e for
review system smoking is known to compromise the
equilibrium and balance of the
immune system this increases the race for
several immune and auto-immune disorders with
diseases caused when the immune system mistakes
and  It is about healthy cells and tissues
Classic example of this in future
replacement of COPD Introduce
Motors People who suffer long duration hanging
OPD and Chronic Obstructive Pulmonary
Disease free problem disease initial delimitation
cost destroyed and patient
suffers from shortness of breath and
desires the destruction of Lord  Krishna The
Destruction of Glum Tissue Spot Boy
and Own Immune Cells Like Macrophages
Smoking Damages Cells Present in
Respiratory System Cells and Married and
Chemicals and Signals Macrophages
Destroy and Own This 2.1 Damage
Exams and Alarms Do Not for Basic
Functions of Class Six Change NDA to
COPD Sudhir Way Smoking Affects Your
Review System As Well As The Systems Of
Smoking subscribe The Channel Please
subscribe and Heart Withdrawal Symptoms Can
Insist He Gets More Serious Serious Topic
Structure of Immune System and
Very Important Mode on the The The The The
Thank You So Much  For watching this video I hope you like this
video see you in next